All right, bladesmiths,
the kill test.
Doug?
[music playing]
The sword to see what
kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do.
I will take your sword and
deliver lethal cuts and stabs
on this ballistics dummy.
All right, Derek.
Ready for this?
I think so.
I'm really looking forward to
see how the blade performs.
But at the same time, I'm
nervous about the blade
catching in a rib and snapping.
Come on, baby.
My heart is in my
throat right now.
[music playing]
Oh my gosh.
All right, Derek.
Let's talk about your
blade right here.
It is light.
It is pointy.
It is sharp.
Your weapon will kill.
DEREK: Thank you.
Good job.
Bob, it's quite something
to follow up with.
You ready?
That's what I came for.
My heart is just pounding.
I mean, I have confidence, but
you don't really know because I
haven't done any tests.
I didn't even stab a watermelon.
[music playing]
Nice work.
All right, Bob.
The point is sharp
enough to deliver
a straight thrust all the way
through this ballistics dummy.
Your weapon, sir, will kill.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, welcome to our
strength test, the flex test.
What I want to do is take
each of your smallswords
and bend them 45 degrees
in both directions.
And if you nailed your
heat-treated construction,
everything should stay true.
How are you feeling, Derek?
- Go ahead.
MAN: All right.
Stood up.
Well, Derek, I'm
very impressed.
This sucker went 45
degrees both ways.
Great job.
- Thank you.
Bob, you ready?
Yeah, I think so.
Now, I'm really worried.
I had to forge it
out in one day.
I had to assemble it
all in the same day
to get everything
put together just
so I could turn in a sword.
I mean, I'd already broken one,
so I knew it could be brittle.
[music playing]
Each degree that it's
going, I'm going,
is it going to break here?
Is it going to break here?
Agonizing.
OK.
Come back now.
Then you go to the other side.
[music playing]
Well, Bob, good news is
your blade didn't break.
What a relief.
Didn't spring back to true,
but it did come most of the way
back.
Overall, nicely done.
Thank you.
Bob, Derek, both of
your finale weapons
were strong, deadly, and sharp.
However, there can only be
one "Forged in Fire" champion,
and that champion is--
Derek, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Bob, unfortunately,
your smallsword
did not make the cut.
Bob, you made a
beautiful sword.
But during that strength
test, your blade
took a bend that set that
didn't straighten out,
and that's why we're
letting you go.
I understand.
Please surrender your blade.
Oh, I absolutely agree
with the judges' decision
that Derek did have
the better blade.
I may not have been called
"Forged in Fire" champion,
but I gained so much
more valuable experience
that it's immeasurable.